TUCKER CARLSON SHOW.
>> Tucker: AMEN!
>> Sean: BUCKLE UP, WELCOME TO
"HANNITY" ," NEW INFORMATION ABO
"HANNITY" ," NEW INFORMATION ABT
THE DIRTY DOSSIERS AUTHOR,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
WE WILL ALSO BRING YOU SOME GOOD
NEWS FOR LIEUTENANT GENERAL
MICHAEL FLYNN, AND HIS BATTLE
AGAINST THE WITCH HUNT, WHICH
CONTINUES.
FIRST, WE START WITH
BOB MUELLER.
NEXT WEDNESDAY, THE CAPTAIN OF
THE WITCH HUNT HIMSELF, WELL, HE
SCHEDULED TO APPEAR BEFORE
CONGRESS IN HIS FIRST AND ONLY
PUBLIC HEARING.
DEMOCRATS ON THE INTEL AND
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES ARE
DEMANDING THAT MUELLER TESTIFY.
ACCORDING TO OUR OWN, HE IS
SAYING THESE VERY SAME DEMOCRATS
ARE NOW WORRIED THAT THIS
POLITICAL STUNT IS ABOUT TO
BACKFIRE AND BOOMERANG.
WOW, THAT HAS HAPPENED A LOT,
AND FOR GOOD REASON.
IN HIS ONLY PUBLIC COMMENTS,
RAMBLING CONTRADICTORY 9-MINUTE
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED T
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED A
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED H
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED E
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED W
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED U
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED D
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED N
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED T
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED E
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED P
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED U
PRESSER, ROBERT MUELLER STATED D
ON ANY OF HIS FINDINGS.
HE SAID THE WRITTEN REPORT WILL
BE HIS ONLY TESTIMONY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE VERY
SAME REPORT THAT CLEARED THE
PRESIDENT OF COLLUSION,
CONSPIRACY WITH RUSSIA AND
DIDN'T CHARGE HIM WITH ANY
OBSTRUCTION.
BY THE WAY, HE WAS NOT CHARGED
WITH OBSTRUCTION.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL,
OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL ALL SAID
NO, DIDN'T HAPPEN.
MEANWHILE, MUELLER IS CERTAINLY
GOING TO FACE A VERY CRUCIAL
QUESTIONS FROM REPUBLICANS.
QUESTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
ANSWERED AND WE ARE GOING TO
PREVIEW THOSE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS IN A MINUTE.
THIS NOW COMES AS A REPORTER IS
NOW OUT THAT THE DOJ IS BLOCKING
HOUSE DEMOCRATS FROM QUESTIONING
TWO MEMBERS OF MUELLER'S
PARTISAN TEAM IN A CLOSED-DOOR
HEARING.
HERE WITH MORE, CHAD PERGRAM IS
WITH US.
WHAT IS THE LATEST?
IT'S BECAUSE THERE WAS A MEETING
TONIGHT BY DEMOCRATS ON THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THE STRUCTURE OF
THIS HEARING WITH BOB MUELLER NX
THIS HEARING WITH BOB MUELLER NT
WEEK.
THERE IS AN OLD SAYING ON
CAPITOL HILL THAT NOTHING IS
DECIDED UNTIL EVERYTHING IS
DECIDED.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE A TWO HOUR HEARING
FOR MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AT 9:00, THERE WILL BE
A BREAK AND THEN THEY ARE COMING
BACK WITH MEMBERS OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
THE QUESTION IS, IS THIS ENOUGH
TIME?
IT WAS VERY INTERESTING SEEING
MEMBERS COMING OUT OF THIS
CLOSED-DOOR MEETING SAYING
EVERYTHING IS IN FLUX, THINGS
HAVEN'T BEEN DECIDED YET.
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD BY MULTIPLE
DEMOCRATS THAT THEY ARE STILL
NEGOTIATING WITH BOB MUELLER'S
TEAM ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF
THIS.
MEMBERS REALLY DIDN'T WANT TO
TALK AS THEY CAME OUT.
THEY WERE DEFERRING TO
JERRY NADLER, THE CHAIR OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, AND MANY,
LOU CORREA, A DEMOCRAT FROM
CALIFORNIA, ANOTHER DEMOCRAT
FROM WASHINGTON STATE, BOTH OF
THEM SAID THAT SOME OF THIS MAY
NOT BE RESOLVED UNTIL THE DAY OF
THE HEARING.
PARTIAL PAL, FRESHMAN DEMOCRAT
FROM
FLORIDA.
IF YOU CUT THIS DOWN TO TWO
HOURS AND TWO HOURS, THERE ARE
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER THE
FRESHMAN AND JUNIOR MEMBERS
WOULD GET A CHANCE TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
ONE SAID, WELL, I HOPE SO.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS STILL UP
IN THE AIR HERE IS THAT THERE
WOULD BE A CLOSED-DOOR
SESSION.
ERIC SWALWELL, A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
THE PROBLEM FOR DEMOCRATS HERE,
IF MUELLER JUST STICKS TO THE
FOUR CORNERS OF THE REPORTED
DOESN'T GO BEYOND THAT, HAVE
DEMOCRATS OVERPLAYED THIS
QUESTION RIGHT THERE IS ANOTHER
EXPRESSION HERE, CAVEAT EMPTOR,
BUYER BEWARE.
MAYBE THIS TURNS OUT TO BE
PRETTY BORING IF ROBERT MUELLER
IS JUST GOING THROUGH DOGEARED
PAGES AND READING BACK WHEN HE
IS GETTING QUESTIONS.
COULD THAT UNDERMINE THE HYPE IN
SOME WAYS?
AND THAT IS WHAT SOME OF US HERE
AT FOX NEWS WHO HAVE BEEN
REPORTING ON THIS, WE'VE HEARD
THAT MUELLER MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT RELUCTANT TO TESTIFY, OR
THERE MIGHT BE AN EFFORT TO
LIMIT OR CURTAIL HIS TESTIMONY.
BUT WE ARE TOLD THAT HE IS ON
FOR 9:00 NEXT WEDNESDAY MORNING.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, WE WILL BE
WATCHING NEXT THURSDAY.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
BOB MUELLER, HE IS NOT A KING.
HE IS EMPLOYED BY WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ALSO DESERVE
ANSWERS TO OTHER QUESTIONS.
FOR A FEW QUESTIONS I THINK
MUELLER MUST ANSWER, WHY DID HE
HIRE A TEAM WITH NO REPUBLICANS?
ONLY BIG DEMOCRATIC DONORS QUEST
REQUIRED IS HE HIRE CLINTON'S
FORMER ATTORNEY?
WHY DID HE HIRE THE GUY, OH,
YEAH, SIDNEY POWELL EXPOSED THE
EVER SO OVERZEALOUS PROSECUTOR,
MUELLER'S PIT BULL
ANDREW WEISSMANN TO LEAD THE
INVESTIGATION.
AFTER ALL, HE WAS AT THE CLINTON
ELECTION NIGHT PARTY THAT NEVER
HAPPENED, LIKELY SOBBING WITH
EVERYONE ELSE THERE.
HE HAS AN ATROCIOUS TRACK RECORD
OF WITHHOLDING EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE, NUMEROUS CASES
OVERTURNED, CONVICTIONS
OVERTURNED BECAUSE OF
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE WITHHELD,
AND ALSO, WHY DID MUELLER HAVE
TIME TO INVESTIGATE MEDALLIONS,
LOAN APPLICATIONS, TAX FRAUD,
BUT NOT FISA ABUSE AND NOT A
PAID FOR A RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
IF HE CARED ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, AND IN THE 2016
ELECTIONS, WHY DID HE THEN NOT
HAVE ANY PROBE INTO
HILLARY CLINTON'S AND DIRTY
DOSSIERS?
THE ONE WITH RUSSIAN LIES, THE
ONE THAT WAS DISSEMINATED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION.
NOW, WHERE WAS THE DEEP DIVE
INTO THE EX-FOREIGN SPY,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE?
WHAT ABOUT FUSION GTS?
THEIR CONNECTIONS TO UNSAVORY
CHARACTERS AROUND THE WORLD AND
THEIR FOUNDER, GLENN SIMPSON.
WHEN DID MUELLER DETERMINED THAT
THERE WAS NO TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION?
WHY DIDN'T HE STOP THEN?
WHY DID THE INVESTIGATION
CONTINUE AFTER THAT
CONTRADICTION AND WHY DID
MUELLER CONTRADICT HIMSELF
DURING HIS NINE AND HALF IN A
PRESS CONFERENCE?
REMEMBER THOSE SPECIAL COUNSEL
CLAIMED THERE WAS NO
OBSTRUCTION.
HE SAID THAT YOU NUMEROUS
PEOPLE.
THEN AT THE PRESSER, HE
SUGGESTED THERE MIGHT'VE BEEN
OBSTRUCTION BUT A SITTING
PRESIDENT CANNOT BE CHARGED
BECAUSE THE DOJ POLICY.
THAT WAS WHEN HE RELEASED A
JOINT STATEMENT WITH ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR'S OFFICE THAT THERE
WAS NO CHARGEABLE OBSTRUCTION.
REGARDLESS OF DOJ POLICY AND THE
ABILITY TO CHARGE A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
SO WHY THE CONFUSION, WHY THE
CHANGE?
WHO WROTE THOSE WORDS?
WHO WROTE THE REPORT?
WERE YOU BEING TOLD WHAT TO SAY
BY ANDREW WEISSMANN, YOUR
PITBULL?
BECAUSE THE WHOLE WITCH HUNT WAS
A DISASTER FROM BEGINNING TO
END.
A MAJOR DISTRACTION FROM REAL
ABUSES OF POWER TAKING PLACE
RIGHT UNDER YOUR NOSE.
JUST LOOK AT THE FROTH OF THAT
TOOK PLACE SURROUNDING THE FISA
WARRANT.
YOUR BUDDY JIM COMEY SIGNED IT,
THE FIRST ONE.
AGAINST THE TRUMP ASSOCIATE,
CARTER PAGE, AND THAT GAVE THEM
A BACKDOOR TO SPY INTO ALL
THINGS TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEN TRUMP TRANSITION, THEN THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY, AND AS
"THE DAILY CALLER" POINTS OUT,
THE BUREAU'S DESPERATE ATTEMPT
TO ACQUIRE A WARRANT WERE
TOTALLY STALLED UNTIL
STEELE DOSSIER CAME ALONG.
DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE SAID IT PERFECTLY.
NO DOSSIER, NO FISA WARRANT.
JAMES COMEY AND COMPANY WERE SO
DESPERATE TO FIND THAT BACKDOORI
DESPERATE TO FIND THAT BACKDOORT
DESPERATE TO FIND THAT BACKDOORO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, YES,
MR. COMEY, TO SPY -- THAT THEY
USED PHONY UNVERIFIABLE CAMPAIGN
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR OP
RESEARCH FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES.
THAT WAS TO OBTAIN A WARRANT TO
SPY ON AN AMERICAN CITIZEN AND
AN ENTIRE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
AND ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
INVESTIGATORS WORKING FOR THE
IG'S PROBE INTO FISA ABUSE, THEY
ASKED CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
"WHETHER THE BUREAU WAS OVERLY
RELIANT ON THE RUSSIAN EXPERTISE
OF OUTSIDERS LIKE HIMSELF."
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE TOLD THEM
THAT
HE BELIEVED THE FBI WAS PROBABLY
UNDEREQUIPPED TO JUDGE THE
INHERENTLY MURKY INTELLIGENCE
THAT HE WAS RELATING.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IS TRUE,
EITHER."
THE TIMES" SAYS THAT HE ADDED
HIS OWN INTERPRETATION TO HIS
OWN SOURCES THAT HE PASSED ON TO
YOUR CHRISTOPHER STEELE, CALLING
INTO QUESTION THE RELIABILITY OF
ALL THIS INFORMATION.
BY THE WAY, THEY WERE ALL WARNED
ABOUT IT BEFORE HE SIGNED IT IN
2016, THE ONE HE SWORE WAS
VERIFIED AND TRUE, THE ONE IN
THREE MONTHS LATER HE TOLD
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S UNVERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS.
IN OTHER WORDS, A SO-CALLED
INTELLIGENCE AND THE DOSSIER WAS
SOURCED WITH SECOND, THIRD HAND
INFORMATION.
ALL TURNED OUT TO BE FALSE, AND
PERHAPS JUST COMPLETELY MADE UP
OR MAYBE AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
PREVIOUSLY SUGGESTED, IT WAS
RUSSIAN MISINFORMATION ALL
ALONG.
BY JAMES COMEY, OTHERS SWORE THA
BY JAMES COMEY, OTHERS SWORE THT
THEIR INTELLIGENCE WAS TRUE AND
ACCURATE.
THAT IS BROAD, PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
PREMEDITATED CONSPIRACY TO
COMMIT FRAUD ON A FISA COURT TO
SPY ON AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE TO HELP ONE CAMPAIGN
WENT AND THE OTHER CAMPAIGN
LOSE, THEN IT BECAME AN
INSURANCE POLICY, AS WE ALL
LEARNED MONTHS LATER.
BUT DESPITE HIGH-RANKING
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS TURNING THE
MOST POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE NEED TO
KEEP US SAFE AGAINST ENEMIES,
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC, WELL, THEY
TURN THEM ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND OTHER AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
THE TRANSITION TEAM, AND ON THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
WE HAVE FOUR SEPARATE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION INVESTIGATIONS, ALL
FOUR CLEARED THE PRESIDENT
OF ANY WRONGDOING.
IF THERE IS NO MORE AMBIGUITY,
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS TO ASK
ANYMORE.
AS DEMOCRATS ARE NOW CONDUCTING
THE FIFTH AND SIXTH
INVESTIGATIONS INTO COLLUSION,
SO-CALLED COLLUSION THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
THE ONLY COLLISION THAT HAPPENED
WAS HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY
DOSSIER.
THAT IS HOW DEMOCRATS ARE
SPENDING YOUR TAX DOLLARS.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE, AT THIS
POINT, THEN PRESIDENTIAL
HARASSMENT AND ABUSE OF POWER BY
THEM.
PEOPLE LIKE JERRY NADLER,
LEADING THESE BRAND-NEW PROBES,
WASTING THE COUNTRY'S TIME AND
THEY ARE NOW HAVING INNOCENT
AMERICAN CITIZENS THAT HAVE TO
ONCE AGAIN LAWYER, THEY ARE
GOING BANKRUPT IN SOME PLACES
AS THEY ARE CALLED TO
ANSWER THE SAME QUESTIONS
FOR FOURTH, FIFTH, SIXTH TIME
AND THEY BETTER ANSWER IT
PERFECTLY, THE WAY THEY DID THE
LAST TIME OR ELSE THEY WILL
DETERMINE THAT THAT IS PERJURY.
THEN THEY WILL BE CHARGED WITH
THAT AND THEY WILL NEED MORE
LAWYERS.
MY ADVICE TO ALL THOSE PEOPLE
THAT WILLINGLY TESTIFY TO
CONGRESS, THAT COOPERATED WITH
THE MUELLER PROBE?
YOU CAN PLEAD THE FIFTH, AND YOU
KNOW WHAT?
IT WON'T COST YOU A DIME.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HIRE ANY MORE
LAWYERS, CAN STAND UP TO THIS
ABUSE OF POWER.
JERRY NADLER AND ADAM SCHIFF,
THEY ARE NO LONGER LAWMAKERS,
THIS ISN'T OVERSIGHT, THIS IS
NOW THEM MERELY CONTENT CREATORS
FOR, WELL, OH, YEAH, MSDN C AND
BRASWELL RACHEL MADDOW'S NONSTOP
ANTI-TRUMP CONSPIRACY HOURS.